Ahead.
Okay,
so the optic today is
to wrap our arms around,
not all but a good portion
of the material covered. Uh,
the book called bottom billion is
somewhat neglected in today's discussion.
What should not be neglected in
your essay is indeed your essays.
Uh,
we'll,
we'll need to take account of many of
the things said by Paul Collier in that,
in that book,
uh,
first of all,
our topic slide here,
you have to ask yourself first what this
guy believes that umbrella is going to
do for him.
And it's,
and I'll show you the subject when slide
in the appropriate place about what
happens neck.
But the gist of that slide is that
capitalism is a dynamic system which is
always leaning forward and is always
within a few months of leaning too far
forward.
It is the nature of the system
you really thought I hit.
Okay.
I'm going to begin by
revisiting the fundamentals,
the systems of ideas that
we began the term with.
And then we'll look at some of
those systems in greater detail.
Tom was small fish
essay on population.
The thesis is that nearly universal
poverty is inevitable because wherever
productivity increases,
population increases a page
and the resources used for
production have diminishing returns.
As you invest more and more labor,
multiple shoes,
obviously thinking about farming and
farming in a small island called England,
and he's wrong.
The world demographic transition,
I've heard we contradict his theory
and the fact that birth rates and death
rates might fall in the precipitous way
they did,
uh,
is the world demographic transition and
is a major key to why the world economy
works the way it does because it
produces an enormous surplus labor in the
societies which pass through
it later rather than earlier.
Similarly,
if we look at Hans Rosling's
wonderful data animation,
which we used on the first day
of class, uh, relating, uh,
life expectancy to GDP per capita,
the world in the last
hundred 20 years has grown.
Rick grown richer on
average five or six fold,
five or 600% richer and healthier,
longer lived.
So that there is a human,
a human project,
a world human project in which the
best of capitalism participate.
And I think that's the
important upside to the topic.
Adam Smith,
invisible hand.
I am Smith has become,
uh,
in death a more famous figure
that he was in life and Ando.
Simpler figure.
The number of people who have actually
read wealth of nations or read it and
theory of moral sentiment
is a tiny fraction of the
people who claim to organize
all their thinking around Adam Smith
and Adam Smith's invisible hand is a
fragile thing which operates
not with giant corporations,
not with oligopolies
knock with monopsonies.
It operates under conditions of
perfect or near perfect competition.
And the porter forces,
which we've seen a direct competition,
the threat of new competition,
the threat of people moving
to substitute project product,
the power of suppliers and the
power of buyers to bargain.
All five of those factors work
against the invisible hand.
The whole point of the porter porter
forces is how vicious corporations avoid
being compelled to behave in the Smithian
way of producing goods and selling
them at or near their marginal costs.
Karl Marx and Joseph Schumpeter.
Yeah,
two great economists to great thinkers.
Uh,
Mark's the founder of a
revolutionary movement, Schumpeter,
uh, a banker, a Harvard professor, uh,
a brilliant intellect,
two ways of looking at the same thing.
What these two guys agree
on is that capitalism is an
inherently unstable moving
system. That the one thing of
which capitalism is, is in capable,
is standing still that liked
the bicyclist in my title slide.
Capitalism always leans forward and
always relies on events in the future,
which are not predictable.
Now,
where the to part ways is
that Mark's is a determinist.
Mark's really thinks that he can foretell
the history of capitalism in its main
outlines
and he was mistaken of that.
We can be sure
show paid or on the other hand believed
that the future of capitalism is
inherently indeterminate.
That there is so much random process,
so much opportunity for
unexpected innovation,
that the prediction of capital,
the behavior of capitalist economies
beyond the very short term, uh,
is impossible. And I'm inclined to
believe the Peter's right about that.
Hi Yak.
Hi.
Eric is the guy who wrote Constitution
of liberty and it's possible to be very
critical of high, actually does play
some logical tricks where this reader,
uh,
on the other hand,
he puts forward a passionate vision about
the creative possibilities of a free
society,
a society in which the right to innovate
the right to choose the right to author
one's own life and proposed
scripts for the lives of others,
a society which is open and not
subject to a overbearing hierarchy and
bureaucracy.
I is a learning machine and Hayak is
a brilliant theorist of that learning
machine.
Another set of fundamentals.
This is Ronald Coase.
He have Coase theorem fame.
This is her Nando de Soto. Uh,
he of mystery of capitalism fame and what
they both say is the capital formation
relies on governments and court and
the formalization of property rights.
And that one of the foundational aspects
of our wealth in the Western world is
tradable property rights
so that our houses are also
are also small store houses
of capital
and are earning power,
can be dot collateral for debt,
which is repaid through future earnings.
That whole aspect of capitalism.
That whole metabolic process is at
the fundaments of the best aspects of
capitalism, the aspects that
involve sustained prosperity.
Okay.
With the remaining 40
minutes of our class,
I'm going to go through these topics.
You can just take a quick glance at them.
They are basically the
details of what I just,
just adumbrated and the last of
them is the case for your final.
Okay?
Okay.
Capital
capital
is accumulated wealth
reproductively deployed.
It can take the form of cultivated land.
It can take the form of seed corn,
it can take the form of factory machinery,
it can take the form
of stock certificates.
It can take the form of educated people.
Indeed,
in a very real sense,
you are in the process
of capital formation.
During your years as university students,
you will be an embodiment of capitol
and indeed capital of a high order.
Uh,
when you finish Yale College or the
school of management or the law school or
whatever it may be, your
last stop. Capitalism,
on the other hand
is the name that Socialists gave to a
whole bunch of things they didn't like
private businesses that in their view
exploited labor in their view despoil the
environment in their view
de sanctified historical,
historical and religious tradition.
And there is no inventor of capitalism.
Adam Smith didn't use the term.
Adam Smith didn't even like
joint stock corporations.
He thought they generally
didn't work well,
but it is an organic system which develops
over time and as Hayak and Schumpeter
and others point out to us is capable
of self modification through time.
Uh,
Marx's historicist theory of this,
and we did a whole lecture
on this in September, uh,
with the idea that capitalism,
capitalism always turns toward monopolies,
that capital becomes too abundant and
the rate of return on it falls with time
that the working class is
eventually eventually starved out.
Immiserated to use the term,
uh,
the inevitable revolution in
advanced capital of systems.
The places the revolution occurred.
We're always in the least
advanced market societies,
places like the Soviet Union.
Uh,
the theory of a universal class that
once the working class capture society,
it,
there will be no class
below it and therefore no
possibility of conflict and uh,
and uh, exploitation, uh,
the withering away of the state.
Okay.
Well here are the places where the
revolution occurred in Rad entered,
occurred in almost all of them because
the capitalist order was not developing
and not maturing rather than that it
was developing and had exhausted itself.
Yeah.
The withering away of
the state takes a while.
Uh, this is from the communist manifesto
and this is where he gets it, right.
The notion that the bourgeoisie that
is capitalist cannot exist without
constitution constantly revolutionizing
the process of production.
That the conservation of old ways of
doing things was characteristic of every
previous economic system,
but not of capitalism.
All that solid melts into air.
So the flat part of
this is pre capitalism.
This was the Angus Maddison
curve that a Clark in,
in his, uh, farewell to arms, uh,
uses as his thesis again
and again and again.
And the upturn corresponds
to the capitalist era. Now,
it also corresponds to the year
of intensive use of fossil fuels.
It also corresponds to the era
of radical urbanization, uh,
and there,
and it also corresponds to a period
of extraordinarily fast technological
innovation.
And you can say that I give capitalism
too much credit and I'll settle for
agreeing with that.
But I will also say that capitalism is a,
has within it indigenously enormous
incentives for continuous technological
innovation and for the rapid
deployment of desirable technologies.
And in that way,
it differs from all of their systems.
Capitalism during its rule of scarce 100
years has created more massive and more
colossal, productive forces that then
have all preceding generations together.
That's a true statement.
It was made in the winter of 1847
48 and it was arguably true then.
It is vastly more obviously true
today that in roughly 10 generations,
maybe 12 generations,
capitalism has created more total
wealth and total spending power.
Uh,
then all the economic systems which
occupied human history before that time.
Now gapminder I'm actually
in a little bit of a,
I don't really have time for
a gap minder exercise, but uh,
there it is.
gapminder.org just go and play it.
Play it for yourselves if you want to
be sure that we're not talking about
something imaginary.
Uh, now what, what
it's an interesting exercise to do is
to single out sub command economies,
uh, such as, uh,
the Soviet Union before in
1989 or Cuba throughout the,
throughout the last 60 years.
And watch them.
And what you'll find is they do relatively
well on the health and longevity
dimension and not so well
on the GDP dimension.
And it is a perfectly
reasonable for someone to say,
I don't care about wealth,
I care about health and good spirit and
all that and I'm not interested in being
part of a society that
generates enormous wealth.
And there are very reasonable and
rational people who take that view.
Um,
and
it's an option and it's fine.
It's even admirable,
but it's not what capitalist
market societies are about.
And one reasonable critique of
capitalist market societies is that they
encourage us all to consume way beyond
our real needs that we spend more money
on clothing and automobiles and
sporting equipment and liquor, uh,
then is really needed.
And there's no doubt of that.
I'm guilty myself.
Uh,
and
my guess is that most of you feel the
pull of market society and the inclination
to spend more than would be
absolutely rational or necessary.
Uh,
fair enough. It's a critique. Uh, and
I think it's, I think it's a valid one.
Yeah.
The state property and capital back to
Smith Smith famously talked about the
nightwatchman state,
the state,
which focuses primarily on law and
order and the enforcement of contract,
the state,
which makes it possible for a person
to own property to deploy that property
productively and to make
money by satisfying the,
the apparent needs of others.
Now in order to have a
night watchman state,
you better have a state and Smith
wrote roughly two centuries,
Rah Rah,
a century and a half after the
Treaty of Westphalia in 1648,
which was the launch point of the modern
nation state system with a monopoly on
force and violence.
And Smith is in a sense
building a theoretical system
on the foundation of state
enforced property rights.
In fact,
it's not just in a way that
is what he does. This was,
these are the states
involved in that treaty. Uh,
this is Thomas Hobbs who's Leviathan is
the defining tracked on nation state,
uh,
and which defines the Leviathan as
a monopolist on force and violence.
We prevent being the victims of one
another by in trusting to the state a full
monopoly on the use of force and violence.
And in that way profit enormously through,
uh,
peace security and the ability to plan
ahead based on our current property
holdings.
The Nation state system lays
out like this. Uh, it is,
uh, in many ways I think you
can say this definitively,
capitalism without the nation
state system is infeasible.
That if there were not the coercive
agency of the state in the background to
vouch safe property and contract,
uh,
to perform the functions, desoto
attributes to it. If it were not for that,
then none of the capital formation
processes that are vital to our wealth,
uh,
would be reliable and feasible.
Now you could invent some
entirely different system.
You could invent a system which slice
the world on another, another angle,
conceivably a functional angle there or
eight or could be a gender organization
in the world. There could be a
state for women in a state for men,
they'd have a geography of,
it would be a little tangled if we
were going to reproduce. But, uh,
the just of the gist of this is that
capitalist wealth rests the foundation of
the nation state system. Uh, and it,
and the nation state system is
not altogether a pretty story.
Here's the British empire as it stood
in 1920 [inaudible] or the 1920s,
and none of these places shown in red
volunteered to join the British empire.
Uh, you might claim that Australia
and New Zealand did I think,
but even that's a reach.
The British empire was an extremely
coercive device for occupying territories
and extracting from their economies a
vast surplus for the metropolitan country.
Uh, it had many knock on
effects which worked out well.
The much of the infrastructure and
educational system which makes India so
promising today,
uh,
is partly related to the
best parts of British Raj.
But the,
the colonial background is a
part of the nation state story.
The function of states
having no state versus a state having a
failed state versus an effective state
having a state which fails to promote
formal property versus one that does the
one point in the tree,
which leads to the existence of what
desoto calls live capital is this one.
And lucky for you and me,
it is the one which envelops our lives
in the United States and in the Western
world.
The and desotos thesis really boils
down to this two by two table with dead
versus live capital and formal
versus informal property rights.
But in the back of this is the notion
that you have to have a state which
effectively and efficiently
administer his property.
And that means an elaborate court system,
a vast number of lawyers,
barristers and the like a
huge record keeping system,
uh,
and and a and behind it all behind it
all a government capable of enforcing,
enforcing property rights
against theft and expropriation.
And this map of this
neighborhood of new haven,
the green lines are the property lines
and the vault at 200 orange street
contains the records corresponded,
corresponded to each of the green polygons
and a in the city there are 26,000
and some green polygons like that.
And the whole surface of North America
is covered with analogous polygon,
which are seed seed points of capital
formation and energize the economy
at desoto.
Construct a strategy of conversion
from dead Capitol Alive,
uh,
toward the back part of the book.
With these phases indicated and in many
parts of the world and much of Latin
America, much of Africa,
some parts of Asia,
the campaign to create live capital,
uh,
is a very real and live a campaign today
and is strategically of considerable
important.
And as you think ahead to the case
you're going to write about in Cochabamba
Bolivia and about which we'll have a few
minutes to talk to or the end of this
class,
the very in formality of that economy
is part of what kills Bechtel and its
development projects.
Yeah.
And the Soto makes quite a lot of how
it is that you can't have an informal
system of property and then
just impose cookie cutter style,
a formal system of property which no one
understands at which doesn't correspond
to their beliefs. You've got to adapt
the formal system to the informal system.
And if the Soto is right and I think he
is part of the brilliance of American,
uh,
property law was that it found ways to
incorporate again and again and again to
incorporate informal property rights
like the Tomahawk farm or the minor's
rights recorded in minors
association records.
Having no relationship to government,
government didn't come along and say, no,
that's all baloney. We're going to do it
our way. Government came along and said,
oh,
we,
she now let's put that into language
which can be incorporated in the law and
which can allow the law to work with
rather than against the property rights
which you have established
among yourselves.
Ron Coast
coast is a Chicago school economist,
uh, and a, and he's written,
he wrote all kinds of a wonderful
scholarship and what's called the Coase
theorem is really post hoc
reinterpretation of his work.
He never sat down to write
a paper called my theorem.
And the insight in it is really pretty
straight forward and I make it a little
simpler than he would like it.
But as we said before, where there
are clear initial entitlements,
the entitlements and the opportunities
to change them are transparent and where
the information is shared in a way that
is relatively symmetrical so that we
don't have situations where a buyer
or a broker knows all kinds of things,
which a customer doesn't know.
I, I, I said that wrong.
Where an owner or a broker knows all
kinds of things which are customer doesn't
know, uh, can finally
low transaction cost.
A practical story.
But any of you ever been involved in
buying a house or being part of a family?
Is it bought a house?
Yes.
Okay. That's informative. Uh, did you, uh,
what did you do to remedy the information
asymmetry between you and the sour?
Right.
You didn't do anything, but when did
your family do visited the house. Okay.
And just that grow,
they had all sorts of papers.
I hope what they did was it hot,
was hired someone to inspect the
house and give them a report.
Let's check with a jet behind you.
Do you ever experienced with it?
Yes,
and I did a praise.
Okay.
You had an appraisal and did you have
anybody to look at the pipes on the roof
and the and all that? Yeah, go ahead.
I'm glad the there,
and I say this because I four or five
years ago bought a house with a slate roof
and I got a report which called the
condition of the slate roof. Very good.
Well it turns out that very good for a
slate roof cost about $20,000 a year in
repairs.
So it was a very bad decision on my part,
but the,
the,
the information shaman tree part of this
is central and the idea is that you can
get an efficient market including any
efficient formation of capital through
leveraging, leveraging real property, uh,
where those conditions are met. So as
a practical guide in, in doing things,
you've got three things to tick off on
your fingers and think about in managing
the affairs of an organization or affirm.
Yeah, this is too complicated. Um,
the rough idea here is to take the three
factors in coasts and run them against
the obvious aspects of
a nation state system.
And look how tech not
say to take an example.
Technology transfer,
uh,
relates to transparency so that we're,
we are one segment of society has unique
access to technology and knowledge that
others lack. You can assume
there will be huge, uh,
huge asymmetries in the distribution of
information and that that will distort
the functioning of the economy.
And sure enough it does.
And part of the justification
for government provision
of public education is
that it provides the minimum access to
information and the methods of obtaining
information which are required by
citizenship in a democratic and market
society.
MMM.
With any market economy you're going to,
you're going to expect to
move east of the status quo.
I did an elaborate exercise with Edgeworth
boxes with you about about a month
ago and where you start
determines where you end.
So if we start here where the
smiths have almost everything,
we're going to end up somewhere up there
or here where the Jones is on almost
everything.
We're going to end up somewhere here.
So what coast doesn't say is that there
is some particular symmetry or justice
to the way property rights move.
And indeed,
it's worth stopping to say
that to ourselves whom so
ever expect social justice
from a market economy expects in vain.
That's not what market economies are
good at. They're good at a lot of things,
but you cannot when you are a wealthy,
a wealthy Septa, judge, Arion,
and I'm at least one of those two things.
You cannot say to yourself that it is
the just verdict of the American economy
that I should be well to do.
I had has it has in it all
kinds of happenstance factors,
uh,
including the luck of one's birth and
the generosity of one's educators that
those things happen. And
so the claim people, I,
I am clearly pro capitalist,
but when I argue with people and
they say, well, but it, it, you know,
there are all kinds of people have more
money than they and others who have last
I say, yes, I agree. Uh,
and there may be other remedies you
want to take for that. For example,
giving some people some of your own money,
but the claim for capitalism
just doesn't go there.
Okay.
Wealth maximizing war and a
joint stock corporation. The law,
the government create,
can either be well designed or
poorly designed to create wealth.
And we started some months
ago with Gan versus rich,
the matter of a sinking whale and
tailoring of the judgment in that case to
preserve the incentive
for the whaling industry.
Yeah.
By allowing the principal deigns to go
to those who take the largest risks and
make the largest investment.
And that's the,
that's the intuition of
wealth maximizing law.
Another case we, I think luck that
I'm not quite sure I would do.
Would you do us versus caused me
the one about their rights? Well,
you get it before the airplane,
it was perfectly sensible to say that
the air rights over one slammed extended
to the end of the universe,
or at least until they got to
the next inhabited solar system.
Uh, that was a perfectly okay
thing to say. It did no harm.
But once air travel became
part of the technology,
you had to change that precept and
grant the right of free trespass above a
certain altitude.
Yeah.
Uh, this is Mark Lanier. I show you
guys a little bit of Mark Linear.
Okay.
And the dark side of wealth Max on the
top side of wealth maximizing law is tort
law and the lawsuit.
But the thinking behind having lawsuits
is that lawsuits provide an incentive
against carelessness in dealing with
the lives of others and the punishment.
That one,
that one that accompany gets for producing
a hazardous product or performing a
risky and failed medical procedure is a
way of keeping manufacturers and health
care people.
Uh,
honest and careful though
critical features,
features
of the Joint Stock Corporation as compared
with straight forward proprietorship
and partnership are first of all that
the chain of accountability is thin.
That is the relationship.
Customers and investors both have only
a thin relationship with the decision
makers in the firm. You
can't, if you own a thousand,
a thousand shares of General Motors
and you think they shouldn't have fired
Fritsch yesterday as they did,
you're going to waste your money by
calling them up to talk about it. Uh,
and if you're the owner of a General
Motors car and you don't like the way the
door handles are put on,
it's not much use calling them up
and asking them to do it differently.
What you have to do is buy
another manufacturer's car. Uh,
the role of ownership is passive investors
buy shares and if they don't like the
course of the company's, uh,
management, they sell the shares.
Uh,
liability is limited.
The most an investor can lose
is what she put in to, uh,
the shares she purchased. That's,
and that's a great provision,
right?
If you're an investor,
it means that you really don't
have to do much homework,
at least homework about the
downside of management practices.
Liquidity is like water.
It is a perfectly liquid instrument and
it is an endlessly scalable instrument.
And the joint stock corporation is about
between 88 to 90% of a market economy
is embodied in joint stock corporations.
And whenever their flaws
and their flaws are many,
Jim Alexander here has told you
a few, uh, their flaws are many.
But uh,
the ability to produce at enormous scale
with enormous efficiency is very real.
I'll post these slides
so you don't need to
write down all my squiggles. Uh, but the,
the most important feature is that
you've got centralized management,
which has a thin Roy ocean ship both with
customers and with investors and is in
it and has the capacity to engage in
efficient production of stuff people
actually want to buy.
Okay.
Vertical integration is a key feature
of companies like this vertical
integration,
meaning that the company engages itself
in a long chain of activities which
start in the extreme case,
start with raw materials.
For example, iron ore in the ground,
tobacco growing in the field,
lobsters crawling about
under Penobscot Bay, uh,
and finishes with lobsters on the plate,
uh,
with a completed
automobile, uh, or whatever.
And vertical integration creates an
enormously difficult management challenge.
And often companies wisely walk
away from some aspect of it.
The car companies,
for example,
have been shedding the manufacturer of
many of their intermediate parks now for
30 or 40 years because it
was so difficult to manage.
But the advantage is that it gives a
company enormous autonomy from others who
seek to intervene in its operations.
The vertically integrated corporation is
also from a public perception point of
view, quite often a monster.
Uh, Alex, I think it was,
uh, referred us to the, to the, uh,
picture of a vampire
squid for Goldman Sachs.
And that picture actually goes back all
this in 1881 cartoon of standard oil
pictured a not as a vampire squid,
but as a giant squid with tentacles
reaching into everyone's living room.
And it was that
a vertical integration from
an olive grove to Palmolive soap.
That's the gist of this.
The slogan on the Palmolive soap,
I learned from, from a beauty
expert how to hold my husband.
That's a terrible way to sell
people soap, right? It's just raw,
right?
It just is.
But marketing does that and it's part
of the package in a capitalist market
society.
Okay.
Uh, the first great corporations
where the American American railroads,
or at least in American history and
the Alfred Chandler piece about the
Pennsylvania railroad is a
good example of this. They,
they involved enormously large,
large scale investment of capital in
the railroad infrastructure and rolling
stock. And they created a
challenge to management,
which no previous business had created.
So you've got 50,000 employees and
you've got these enormous contraptions
running at one another, uh, all
over the place. And incidentally,
in the early years,
killing five or 10,000 people a year
and the management of all that required.
One of the great revolutions, which I
have spent little time on in this course,
where in the joint stock corporation,
you develop a huge cadre of
professionally trained managers, uh,
like the crowd sitting back, right? Uh,
soon to be a freshly minted
Yale Mbas who are going to run.
I don't think you're going to run trains.
Uh,
but they're going to run
big complicated things.
Goldman Sachs
is a different kettle of fish.
Goldman Sachs is not
vertically integrated at all.
It occupies a strategic
position in the economy,
which allows it economy and government,
which allows it to create,
to use enormous leverage
and enormously high powered,
uh,
expertise to generate revenues on a more
or less unprecedented scale and polos.
And noni is my very dear friend.
Uh, he really is. I mean,
we're really good
friends. Um, but I would,
I would say I would say it to his face.
I probably wouldn't say it in front
of a hundred people to his face,
but I would say to his face that
he earns way too much funny,
just outrageous how much money you earn.
Now I,
I wouldn't advance a law to
take his money away, but I,
I do think there's more of it than he
needs or deserves. But like I said,
capitalism doesn't solve that problem.
Um,
this is the inner courtyard at
Infosys in Bangalore in India.
And the process of very rapid formation
of gigantic wealth in through the,
through the best joint stock
corporations is a worldwide event.
Uh, and the world would be a better
place if there were more of it.
The,
the
Ibbotson slides, which I
showed you some months ago, uh,
for the u s summarize what becomes of a
dollar invested in 1927 as common stock.
And that kind of growth is
characteristic only of very well managed.
Uh, equity investments, greater
possibilities with free society.
Okay.
Hi Act conceives of society
as a learning machine
and that store of knowledge
and institutional practices
which are built up in a,
in a,
in a market society.
Okay
bill up in an exponential way
like the green curve here.
And the most important fact
about that is that no individual
knows a very high fraction of the
total knowledge of the system.
We are all,
we all need to be shelf consciously
humble about how little it is.
We know about the total
operation of the system.
We are all looking at 1% 3% 2% of the
data which make our society function or
fail to do so. And that condition,
it's more and more obvious, right?
If you think about what it
is that is on the screen in,
in your,
on your study desk,
what's accessible in that screen at
any given moment is thousands of times,
thousands of times more
than you will ever command.
I'm going to have to stop there with
that and go back and go to the case
because,
um,
I want to have time for that and a post.
I've got three or four more topics there,
but I,
I'll post the slides and I want
to discuss the case with you,
um, of, can we turn this?
Yeah. Here we go. Um,
were you, how many of you were able
to look at the Finnegan piece so far?
Got Your attention. Go ahead. Um,
you audit,
start by,
I would,
I would start interpreting this story by
asking yourself about Bolivia's history
and social composition
and where it Phipps, uh,
in the world economy,
how it relates
to Paul Collier's bottom billion.
Yeah.
And here's one obvious
way it relates call your,
has a series of what he calls traps.
If you're running Bolivia through all
the traps, you will see that it is an,
it is not a favored nation.
It is a nation which has
many vulnerabilities,
and it is consequently on the
lower edge of the world economy.
Now,
it has a city called Cochabamba,
about 800,000 people,
uh, with a, uh,
water company called a
water agency called cm pos.
And that agency is terrible.
It does a very poor job
of delivering water.
Uh,
it is also corrupt and a very high
fraction of the water distributed is
distributed illegally.
People tap into it just
as in poor countries,
people tap into the power line,
power cables that run through their areas.
And the,
there are two gigantic agencies,
the World Bank and the
international monetary,
which believe in markets in a big way.
And they have a pressured Bolivia and uh,
50 or 75 similar bottom billion countries
to marketize their economies through
private investment.
And the gist of the story is that the
investment of private capital will
incentivize companies typically well,
well finance, Josh, Josh,
joint stock corporations to do an awful
lot better job of providing water,
electricity, a rail service, air service,
uh,
all the basic functions of an economy
will be better performed privately then
they were publicly.
And the people who are of the inspirers
of that are called the Chicago Boys
Group of young economists,
the most famous of whom is Jeffrey Sachs,
who was then at Chicago
but is now at Columbia.
Uh,
and the market tonic is what
was applied in this case.
Now the case didn't work,
the, the tonic didn't work.
And one conclusion,
one conclusion is that market
reform is all together wrong
and we'll fail everywhere.
And I think you can gather some evidence
through your reading and through
Collier one way or the
other. On that point, uh,
the gist of the question,
which I'll post tomorrow,
is
explain what happened when Bechtle
through its wholly owned subsidiary,
went into Cochabamba to
reconfirm reconceived,
reconfigure and reconstruct
the water system,
interpret that story in light of the
most important things you've learned in
this course.
Are there questions?
Okay, we'll see each other again
on December 14th at the exam.
[inaudible].